[Musique]
ludovic romain bonjour bonjour monsieur
divo vie alors vous êtes candidat de la
martinique ensemble sur la première
circonscription celle du centre
atlantique qu'est ce qui a motivé votre
candidature
alors vous savez quand déjà en tant que
marty dickey vous voyez au quotidien des
difficultés qui se posent et qui ne
semble pas avoir de réponse c'est la vie
chère par exemple vous avez le problème
de l'emploi chez les jeunes vous avez
l'accompagnement de nos aînés quand vous
voyez déjà 100 en tant que citoyen ça ne
peut pas vous laisser insensible
et puis après vous avez au niveau
professionnel puisque je suis avocat de
profession vous avez les mêmes constats
que vous faites puisque vous aider vous
défendez les gens mais derrière vous
avez une réalité qui fait que ya ces
problèmes récurrents un commun qui
viennent s'ajouter au fur et à mesure ça
ne peut pas vous laisser insensible
et c'est pour ça que sur la question des
législatives
le combat qui aura amené naturellement
l'assemblée nationale pour régler ces
problèmes là de toute manière concernant
tous les citoyens mais singulièrement
des martiniquais c'est ce qui a fondé
mon engagement je ne peux plus - ajout
d'une terre il faut dire stop à un
moment donné puis avec dignité travail
que nous puissions aller se battre pour
obtenir acquérir nos droits et qu'on les
respecte
dans quel état d'esprit
êtes vous
ce n'est pas une circonscription facile
il ya dix sept candidats dont quatre
avocats oui mais il faut faire preuve de
conviction vous savez je croyais au
contraire salué l'ensemble des personnes
qui qui s'engagent dans la mesure où si
nous faisons la démarche c'est bien
qu'il y à une crise qui est profonde
donc les 17 candidats font preuve
d'abnégation de courage et exposent leur
point de vue aux compatriotes l'idée de
dire aujourd'hui que hongrois convaincre
on doit convaincre par les idées par la
posture et par la sincérité il faut
faire confiance à l'intelligence des
compatriotes à l'intelligence du
martiniquais qui a toutes les capacités
de comprendre les enjeux et il état
d'esprit celui là uniquement la
conviction et notre travail nous ne
sommes pas l'ajout du je ne vais pas su
le tiret ou tirer sur un tel tir et sion
et elle en disant que rien n'a été fait
c'est pas ça je crois qu'il faut qu'on
sorte de ce schéma là l'idée c'est que
il faut que nos concitoyens
les compatriotes puissent savoir
exactement ce que nous voulons pour nous
si vous êtes élu ou allez vous siégez ce
cas gauche c'est-à-dire jusqu'à n'y
avait que macron n'y avait que la
majorité du président actuel ni à droite
et quand je dis à gauche et que pour
l'heure vous avez vu la refonte du front
de gauche il faut savoir après les
élections les a conquis son prix la
manière qu'on aura de s'entendre sur les
sujets principalement ceux qui occupent
les martiniquais mais ce sera
nécessairement me concernant à gauche
c'est à dire dont le nouveau front de
gauche qui a été créé à travers le la
nouvelle union populaire concernant donc
on revient à vos propositions concernant
donc la circonscription de laquelle vous
présentait donc c'est la première
circonscription quels seront vos deux
trois grandes priorités en tant que
député je crois que fondamentalement il
rennes première c'est la vie chère vous
ne pouvez pas le 10 du mois pour la
plupart des martiniquais vous grattez
derrière la tête pour savoir comment on
va définir le mois et comment vous allez
faire pour donner à manger à vos enfants
parce que la vie ne se résume pas à ça
et donc s'il ya un combat à mener si la
transparence des prix c'est possible à
travers la loi on peut organiser une
transparence calais où les prix pour
essayer de voir quel prix nous allons
bloquer quels produits vont être soumis
au jeu de la loi dans la mesure où ça
s'est engagé dans le temps il ya un
deuxième combat fondamentalement c'est
une question de santé publique je prends
deux exemples vous avez deux côtés le
chlordécone et de l'autre les sargasses
ce combat là n'est pas un combat
uniquement martiniquais puisque ce
phénomène rare à ces deux phénomènes la
touche également la guadeloupe nous
allons avoir sur ces sujets là nous
allier pour pouvoir avoir plus de poids
et dit réalité qui ne doit pas ses
responsabilités parce que vous avez des
choses qui se font ici qui ne se ferait
jamais en hexagone il faut qu'on puisse
le dire très clairement sur l'exemple
des sargasses il ya eu ce problème la
bretagne les algues vertes a été traité
par l'état c'est une question de santé
publique et l'état aujourd'hui de quoi
garantir ce droit à la santé et des
martiniquais parce que au risque de se
diriger vers un scandale cours
d'économie ou 2 ou dans 20 ans on va
apprendre que finalement c'était
extrêmement nocif pour la santé et que
ces générateurs le cancer moi je crois
que dès aujourd'hui il faut que l'état
prend toute transparence prenne ses
responsabilités il faut que les
parlementaires guadeloupéen et
martiniquais puisse s'allier pour dire
ça suffit les moyens ce ne sont pas aux
communes de limite ce n'est pas la
collectivité territoriale ce n'est pas
aux particuliers de le faire c'est à
l'état d'un concert avec toutes ces
personnes là pour pouvoir le faire le
plus efficacement que possible dernière
question qu'avez vous à dire aux
électeurs aux électeurs pour les
convaincre de voter pour vous alors de
faire preuve de manière générale de
clairvoyance vous savez on a une
pratique qui consiste quasiment à mettre
la main des gens dans l'ump ou du goûter
pour moi aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ma
démarche ma démarche est de dire si
j'arrive à vous convaincre c'est à dire
que les idées quand je porte les idées
que je défends les postures que j'adopte
en sincérité si cela vous convient alors
oui donnez moi la force l'énergie je
pense l'avoir joly il me faut maintenant
la force de ma population de mes
compatriotes qui disent ça suffit il
faut qu'à l'assemblée nationale on est
quelqu'un qui nous défendent et qui sera
aussi proche de nous parce que le député
doit à la fois se faire entendre mais il
ne doit jamais ou jamais se couper des
préoccupations de ses compatriotes donc
c'est uniquement ce que j'ai à dire voir
en toute sincérité à mes compatriotes
son ton de ce qu'on faisait avant il
faisons comment merci de votre copain
[Musique]